if the fire alarm should sound
please leave the meeting room by the
follow by following the fire exit signs
please switch off all mobile phone
phones
or turn them to silence please mark
yourself as present
on the modern gov app if you haven't
already done so
counsellors should keep their face masks
on unless they are speaking
if you wish to speak please indicate the
chair
and move to a lake vacant land lectern
there are three lecterns one behind you
and one on either side
councillors should remain in their seats
and observe the two-meter rule
at the end of the meeting please leave
the meeting room as quickly as possible
do not congregate inside this meeting
room
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except where there are confidential
or exempt items if you make a
representation to the meeting
you will be deemed by the council to
have consented to have been filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council
and to the possible use of those images
and sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council
members of the public and the press may
record
film photograph or broadcast this
meeting
when the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
i'd now like to say a few words as the
outgoing chairman
first of all i am so happy to be meeting
in person again
i can't tell you how pleased i am to see
you
and did not have to say welcome to this
virtual meeting of the council
i'm sure there will be mixed views
amongst members and officers
i was first proposed as chairman of
baber district council
in may 2019 i was honored
surprised and thrilled
thank you to the leader john ward and
deputy leader
clive arthy and all my fellow
councillors for selecting me
i recall my speech was full of
excitement and plans
i announced my chairman's charity as
hadley action dementia alliance
and later added hadley scouts and guides
hadley as a town was very proud that i
had been selected
and i hope i have raised the profile of
the town
i was so proud to represent baber
district council
at many and various civic events ranging
from fantastic visits
to the very dynamic west suffolk college
through to celebrating the success of
the rural coffee caravan
i also attended various civic services
i got to be quite practiced at knowing
when to wear thermals
as a procession might mean cueing
outside i was also pleased to be asked
to open the amazingly successful hadley
on show community day
which i was also on the committee of
a local committee met regularly to plan
the chairman's ball
to raise funds for my charities the band
venue caterers were all booked and it
was a hot ticket in town
as you may have guessed a suitably
glamorous ball gown was enthusiastically
purchased
while initially nervous i enjoyed taking
the council meetings
and have particularly enjoyed
encouraging new members to contact me
and behind the scenes trying to give
them confidence to become involved in
the meetings
but what a difference 15 months makes
first i wish to thank again the leader
deputy leader
and fellow councillors for proposing me
for a second term
however from three quarters through the
first term
it was clear that things were going to
change
no more representing the council at
civic events
and the board dress is still hanging
unused
it may have looked a little overdressed
to wear it to morrison's
which was about the only place i visited
during lockdown
in came online meetings it was scary
suddenly being thrown into handling such
large meetings
in this new format where we were all
learning on the job
during the lockdown i really missed
seeing people
like many while there were the
conveniences
of working from home i did miss bumping
into officers
and fellow councillors at endeavour
house the whole collegiate experience
but i found a new team a small group of
officers who i met with just once a
month
and who i felt i belonged with for the
evening
we learned together where we should sit
safely
yet still be able to communicate with
each other
the technical aspects of how to take the
meetings
how to handle huge numbers in the room
but not physically see
and to ensure that the meetings still
retain dignity
and purpose it is to this
team that i as chairman which to give my
thanks
as i really could not have coped so well
as the front man
without the enormous help and advice of
in particular
jan robertson who i enjoyed planning the
meetings with
and also emily your mandy smith
and robert carmichael who either in
front
or behind the screen gave me much
valuable support
their help during so-called normal times
would have been enormous and appreciated
but it is during these lot town times
when the meetings took on such an
intense atmosphere
and required so much planning that i
really appreciated their advice
and wish to thank them for their support
i would also like to thank karen sayer
who's been a great help to me on so many
occasions
special thank you goes to civic officer
pauline taylor
so much happens in the civic office that
has a member we are not aware of
and pauline is the guru everyone turns
to
she is the one who administers the diary
advises on protocol leapt into action
for the council's appropriate response
when the duke of edinburgh died and she
ensures that the pacific office runs
smoothly
pauline retired a few days ago she
started at baber
in april 1974 when it was formed
and left and returned after having
family
she came back last in 2006
so achieved another 15 years with baber
pauline was our civic officer for her
last 12 years
i'm sure you'll wish to join with me in
wishing pauline a very happy and
deserved retirement
we have all learned to work in new ways
since march 2020
and we as a council can feel proud
of how we have how we have responded
to the challenges of the covert crisis
in all respects i have been grateful for
my terms as chairman and enjoyed them
even though they might not have been
entirely as i would have chosen
additionally sadly i was not able to
raise as much money for my charities as
i would have hoped
but on reflection far far worse times
have been experienced by others in baby
during this period
thank you all to the officers and
councillors for your dedication during
this time
and to john ward and arthur charnovia
for your leadership during this
challenging time
and so thank you fellow officers and
councils fellow councillors and officers
for your patience and support during my
time as chairman
and i thank you also for being so well
behaved in the chamber
or virtual chamber during my tenure
i don't think i've had to face any
jackie weaver moments during our
meetings
the last and by no means the least
person i would like to thank
is my vice chair adrian osborne
he has always been there as a support to
me and to the office during my term
thank you adrian and i hope councillors
without wishing to preempt the vote that
you will give him
or any chairman you elect as much
support
as you offered me thank you all
[Applause]
so i'll now move to the gender thank you
everyone
election of the chairman of the council
please can i have nominations for the
position of
chairman of the council councillor john
ward
thank you
thank you that's adrian osborne has been
nominated by councillor john ward
can i have a seconder please
counselor clive arthy thank you thank
you
are there any further nominations
if there are no further nominations i
will now ask
the corporate manager governance and
civic office
to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors if you go to
the modern.gov app
that vote is in there showing blue if
you click on it you can cast your
vote thank you
you need to vote
councillor jameson are you able to vote
sorry councillors i'm going to ask you
to ask you to take that again that
hasn't taken the vote so can you all
um just um vote again
yeah and it came up on green as carrie
did it
sorry it seems to have reset itself so
if we could just take that again
foreign
thank you
councillor dawson are you able to vote
again sorry thank you
okay um chair that is 26 votes for one
against and one abstention thank you
thank you so the vote is carried and i
have much pleasure in declaring
that councillor adrian osborne is duly
elected
as chairman of baber district council
[Music]
do you want to sign the book now
i adrian osborne
having been elected to the office of
chairman of the council
here by declare that i will take that
office upon myself
and will duly and faithfully fulfill the
duties of it
according to the best of my judgment and
ability
i undertake to be guided by the suffolk
local code
of conduct in the performance of my
functions in that office thank you
[Music]
yes please
[Music]
[Music]
do you want me just
[Music]
firstly i would like to thank councillor
john ward
for my nomination and counselor clive
arthy
for seconding me for the position of
chair of the council
it was very humbling to hear their kind
words
i think
i also like to thank my fellow
councillors
for supporting me i am truly honored to
be elected as chairman
i would also like to give my thanks to
the outgoing chair councillor
grandin members
i certainly have some boots to fill
although i will find it hard to wear
high heeled shoes
she has been an excellent chair and a
credit to baber
in addition to this she has had the
chair through the most challenging times
of this council she has done
this with a smile on her face and has
demonstrated
real professionalism and commitment
it has been a privilege to be her vice
chair for the last two years
thank you catherine i was asked
which charity i plan to support in my
term of office
and the kernels charity came immediately
into my thoughts
i have been supporting kernos for many
years
and i've always been impressed with the
work that they do
and the difference they make to people's
lives and well-being
and hearing some of these stories has
reduced me to tears
kernos is a small charity which has been
operating in sudbury and beyond since
april 2003 providing a professional
counselling
to anyone in need particularly to those
not provided for
on the nhs but have no means of
financing
counselling support kernels is
completely dependent on funding
they receive referrals from all age
groups and from
individuals families schools
gp surgeries social services
children's centers parent support
workers
housing society etc
they support and enable vulnerable
members of the community to work
with their mental health problems and
increase their quality of life
so that they can regain their health and
well-being become
self-sufficient and participate fully in
society they cover a wide range of needs
such as acute anxiety and depression
experiences of bereavement bullying
domestic abuse childhood abuse
eating disorders self-harming and
suicide attempts
we have all been affected by mental
health in one way or another
be it ourselves or a family member
a friend or one of our residents
it is close to all our hearts and will
be even more important to our
communities
as we recover from the last 12 months
it seems very unlikely that i will be
able to hold charity events
in my year so both officers and myself
have given consideration to how we can
continue
to raise funds for this very deserving
charity
therefore i'll be asking members
to make a small donation to my charity
if they wish
two thousand pounds would fund costs for
a councillor
uh twenty twenty pounds per session for
face a half face or online counselling
sessions
or between 12 and 20 people
1000 would provide 50 sessions for
between 6
and 10 people so each contribution
will be gratefully received however
it is your choice but i do hope you will
support this
thank you all again for nominating me as
chairman
i look forward to and i'm proud
to be representing this council for the
next
municipal year and will do so
to the best of my judgment and ability
thank you all i would now like to
move to item two on the agenda election
of vice
chairman of the council
may i have a nomination for vice
chairman
clive
can i have a second please sue
cottondale thank you sue thank you clive
are there any further nominations
that we wouldn't
no then with the nomination i
now ask our corporate manager governance
and civic office to conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair councillors if you go to
the election advice chairman
on your voting screen it is now turning
blue
if you'd like to cast your vote thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
councillor lindsay are you able to cast
your vote or is there an issue
okay can i take your vote um verbally
please
thank you
thank you chair that is 22 votes four
four against and three abstentions
thank you i declare councillor
grandin duly elected hold on catherine
i now invite the vice chairman to sign
declaration of acceptance of office
[Music]
i catherine grandin having been elected
to the office
of vice chairman of the council hereby
declare
that i take that office upon myself
and will duly and faithfully fulfill the
duties of it
according to the best of my ability and
judgment
i undertake to be guided by the suffolk
local code of conduct
in the performance of my functions in
that office
and i just would like to quickly say
thank you very much
to you to those of you that voted for me
and i look forward to supporting adrian
osborne
who i'm sure will be a very excellent
chairman of the council
thank you
all right thank you members i'd now like
to
go to three on the agenda
apologies for absence thank you chair
i have received apologies for absence
from councillor owen
councillor gould and councillor hardacre
thank you
thank you
declarations of interest by councils
are there any declarations of interest
so we return to uh gender item
5 bc 21 stroke 1
to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 23rd of march
2021 for accuracy only
are there any issues with the accuracy
council jan osborne
um thank you chair we will add that um
to the amended minute thank you
kevin oh cath uh councillor mayberry
sorry
you may remove your mask if you wish to
speak
um could i have a proposal please
thank you and a second to please
clive thank you
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office
to conduct the electronic vote thank you
chair
councillors that vote is now open if you
can place your votes please
all right i'm sorry about it
council lindsay would you like to place
your vote verbally
thank you
and councillor plum would you like to
place your vote
verbally
thank you chair that is 29 for
thank you i'd like to go to
item 6 bc 21.2
announcements from the chair and leader
i referred to paper bc 21 stroke 2 for
noting
thank you councillor ward do you have
anything to report
sorry about that i would like to begin
by echoing council grandin and say how
lovely it is to see all of you again in
the flesh
after so long i am relieved to see you
all safe and well after such a traumatic
14 months
let me be the first to congratulate you
mr chairman on your election this
evening
and also to you madam vice chairman i'd
also like to thank you catherine
for your sterling service to the council
during the past two years
that i have included such an unusual
year in 2020
i am pleased that we can at last meet in
person although the unwillingness of
government to extend the legislation
allowing online meetings before the full
removal of covered restrictions
has imposed unnecessary financial and
logistical burdens on us
through having to meet here rather than
our council chamber
we usually only come to western part for
conferences and elections
and so these are unfamiliar surroundings
for us for a council meeting
i am extremely grateful to our own
officers and the staff here at western
park for making this possible
and for ensuring that we can webcast
this meeting as well
i sincerely hope that the government
listens to the responses to the call for
evidence on the future of meetings
and enacts legislation that restores the
ability to hold online meetings
and gives councils the discretion and
flexibility
to decide what is best what is the best
approach locally
many councils such as ours adapted very
well and there were clear benefits in
terms of eliminating travel for
attendees
members officers and the public alike
and also increased public
it strengthened and broadened access to
local democracy at the most important
time
and enabled us to continue to function
and deliver for all of our residents
throughout these difficult 14 months
i know many of you have been shielding
during lockdowns either due to your own
ill health or vulnerabilities
or because you've been carrying uh have
carrying responsibilities for loved ones
in a similar position
so i therefore apologize for putting you
in such a difficult position by asking
you
and the public to attend this meeting
tonight
we have of course put in place all the
covert 19 mitigations that you've become
used to
and would expect and also that you would
expect in order to keep everyone safe
i would like to congratulate those here
who are successful in the recent county
elections
and give my commendations to those who
missed out
i know you all campaigned as well as you
could given the need to respect rules
about social distancing
i would also like to welcome councillor
simon barrett back to baber
following his excellent result in great
corner in the great corner by-election
the suggestion that some of our recent
tough decisions to improve sudbury
are unpopular with the majority of the
residents is simply not borne out by
this result
i guess when it comes to opposition
noise doesn't necessarily equal numbers
it is great to see the count of the
country and our district carefully
unlocking from covert
and so far been able to proceed smoothly
along the government's roadmap
the recent announcement that the suffolk
northeast essex ics has carried out its
millionth vaccination
is wonderful news the vaccination
program is definitely having a
significant effect now with infection
rates
hospital admissions and deaths all at
very low levels
i would like now to confirm the cabinet
change that i reported to you all last
week
as i mentioned councillor parker has an
opportunity
to grow his business and this will take
up a lot more of his time
and he has therefore decided to leave
the cabinet so that he can concentrate
on this
i've asked councilman craw to join in
his place as the cabinet member for
customers digital transformation and
improvement
and i am delighted that he's accepted i
would like to extend a warm welcome to
council mccraw
and i'm sure his experience and sound
judgment will be assets to the cabinet
i would also like to thank councillor
parker for his contribution and
achievements over the past two years
it has been a busy and sometimes
difficult brief as we strive to ensure
that we interact with our customers
through an increased range of media in
ways that suit them in their differing
lifestyles
the past year particularly has thrown up
two significant challenges covered and
the move of the sudbury access point
but councillor parker has been steady at
the helm and we have dealt with these
very successfully
as as a result of the improvements to
our systems and processes during his
tenure
thank you lee for all your work and the
support that you have given me
i think that you may have already heard
the excellent news that our bid to
support rough sleepers across
the two districts has been successful
and
including payments received in april we
have been awarded a total of four
hundred and three thousand one hundred
fifty four pounds
from the government's 203 million pound
rough sleeping initiative funding for
the current financial year
with this additional funding shared
initiatives will be put in place across
baba and mid-suffolk
district councils enabling them to
produce to provide
additional emergency and transitional
accommodation additional support workers
and a dedicated mental health support
service to work with rough
sleepers we are still awaiting the
outcome for
the rough sleeper accommodation program
which will enable us to build five
specialist units of high supported
accommodation
and employ a dedicated support worker to
work with our most
complex cohort and we expect to hear
about this in early june
finally i want to thank all of the
councillors who were able to take part
in the workshops last week
there was maturity of thinking passion
and compassion
as well expressed by everyone who
attended
it was also great to hear so much
agreement and commonality across
political groups
those workshops will help shape our
actions and deliver over the next 12 to
24 months
however there is still the opportunity
to have your say any counsellors who
weren't able to attend
or who wish to contribute their ideas
and views in relation to any of the
workshop themes that they didn't
participate in
can still do so you have all received an
email from deborah largent with a short
form to complete
if you wish to submit your ideas and
please can i ask you to do so by the
deadline of tomorrow
if you haven't already thank you
chairman that's
that's all from me
thank you members like to
go to item seven designation of
committees and joint committees to
appoint the following committees and
joint committees baba overview and
scrutiny committee
planning committee weber licensing and
regulatory
committee
joint audit and standards committee and
joint appointments committee
could i have a proposal to appoint all
the committees listed on the agenda
clive
could i have a second please
sean dawson thank you
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote thank you chair
councillors if you go to that item on
the
modern.gov app it is now showing in blue
for you to place your vote
thank you
right catherine's isn't it okay
okay i'm councillor brandon can i take
your vote verbally please
four councillor lindsay can i take your
vote verbally please
and cancer simon barrett can i take your
vote verbally please
okay that's fine
um chair that is 28 4 and one abstention
so that is carried thank you
that is carried and
item eight bc 21 stroke three
political balance and composition of
committees
i'll refer to you appendices a and b
in the table papers i would like to
invite
the deputy monitoring officer to
introduce paper bc 21-3
thank you each year a local authority is
required to review the allocation of
seats to political group at its annual
meeting
this report is seeking approval of the
numerical allocation of seats as
detailed
in appendix a of this report and that
committee members detailed in
appendix b of the report be appointed to
those committees
the monitoring officer is also
recommended recommending that the
remaining unallocated committee seat be
allocated to councillor owen
who is an ungroup member of the council
thank you
[Music]
thank you questions
could i have a proposal please
clive councillor arthy
and could i have a seconder please
counselor john ward
are there any questions on this
then i will ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair councillors if you go to
that vote
it is now there showing in blue if you'd
like to cast your vote please
thank you
councillor lindsay would you like to
cast your vote
thank you chair that is 29 votes for
that is unanimous and carried thank you
thank you members item nine
election of chairs and vice chairs of
committees
note in accordance with the council's
constitutional
article 6 er 6.2.1
the leader shall take up the
chairmanship of the cabinet
so to elect the chair and vice chair for
the following committees and joint
committees
baba overview and scrutiny committee
planning committee baba license and
regulatory committee
joint order and standards committee
joint appointments committee
can i have uh nominations for chair of
opium scrutiny committee
please councillor john ward
thank you and could i have a second
okay thank you alice councillor alistair
mccrawl
thank you uh are there any further
nominations
i will now ask the as there isn't any i
shall now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
so councillors you will need to scroll
down but the vote will show
in blue for the nomination for
councillor mclaren to be chair of
overview and scrutiny that vote
is now open thank you
you'll vote please
and councillor plum can i take your vote
please
thank you and councillor dawson
thank you
so chair that is 28
four and one abstention that is carried
thank you thank you
that is carried so councilman
mary mclaren a dull appointed chair over
and scrutiny committee
may i have nominations for vice chair of
overview and scrutiny committee
could i have a proposal please clive
arthy
councillor clark harvey captain crandon
could i have a seconder
dave busby councillor dave busby sorry
dave
are there any further nominations
now then i will ask the corporate
manager governance and civic office to
conduct the electronic vote thank you
chair
the vote to elect councillor grandin as
vice chair of baber overview and
scrutiny is now showing in blue
if you would like to place your vote
thank you
councillor lindsay would you like to
place your vote verbally
thank you and councillor plum
thank you chair that is 26
4 2 against and one abstention that is
carried
thank you councillor catherine grandin
is julia appointed uh vice chair of over
scrutiny committee
can i now have nominations please for
chair of planning committee
councillor dave busby
could i have a second please
counselor alastair mccraw
and are there any further nominations
councillor merlini barrett
thank you can i have a second councillor
john ward
so we've had nominations from councillor
dave busby dissected by councillor
cru who was who was it mccraw mccraw
yeah sorry aleister sorry
bigger pardon and
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair so this this vote will
be taken in two stages the first vote
for the first nomination will be for
councillor plum
if that vote receives over 15 votes
then that we won't go to the second vote
so we will open that vote to elect
councillor plum as chair of
baber planning committee that vote is
now in blue if you would like to cast
your vote
15 votes were over sorry yes
councilman lindsay would you like to
cast your vote please
and counselor plum
[Music]
so chair that is 15 for the election of
councillor plum and 14
against so that is carried
do we have to carry the second vote no
we don't
councillor plum is duly appointed to
chair of planning committee
may i have nominations for the vice
chair of planning committee
it's because we had to take two manual
votes
so yeah so we've had we've got to add
two four four councillor plum that's why
it's not showing correctly on there but
we will adjust that manually afterwards
thank you may i have nominations for the
vice chair of planning committee could i
have a proposal
please
counselor john ward
councillor ayers and could i have a
second
please
oh sorry elizabeth malvezy councillor
elizabeth melvacey
thank you are there any further
nominations
[Music]
then no further nominations i will then
ask the corporate manager governance and
civic office
to conduct the electric electronic vote
thank you chair so we are casting a vote
for the vice chair of
the planning committee for councillor
heirs that vote is now
open and showing in blue for councillors
to place their vote
thank you no it hasn't
shown sorry there will be a short delay
um
it is i can see it so you will see it
very shortly
it's not blue it is blue yeah okay sorry
it's just a little bit of delay
lindsay would you like to place your
vote
okay
so chair that is 25 4
councillor airs to be elected and four
abstentions
thank you thank you councillor
suez you're duly elected as vice chair
of planning
may i have nominations for the chair of
license and
a regular uh reggaetoury committee
please
could i have a proposal client council
clervathi
margaret mayberry
could i have a second please
okay councillor plum thank you
uh are there any other nominations
councillor john ward
casey newman could i have a second to
please
councillor sue cartendale thank you
[Music]
are there any other nominations
and i will ask the governance
officer manager governance and civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair so again this will be
two votes if the magic number of 15
or more is not reached in the first vote
so we are voting to elect councillor
margaret mayberry as the chair of
licensing and regulatory
that vote is now open and it should show
in blue
there may be a slightly delay
[Music]
so councillor lindsay would you like to
place your vote
chair that is uh 12 4 and 17
against so that nomination is lost
so go to the next nomination
of counselling newman
can we have the votes for council newman
yeah so chair that um vote will
now um open and show in blue
very shortly
are you able to see that yet you are
right okay
[Music]
councillor lindsay would you like to
place your vote
okay chair that is 17 4
10 against and two abstentions
so that is carried thank you councillor
newman
are duly elected as chair what have we
got up to here i've got
vice chair isn't it yeah vice chairman
i'd like now to uh ask for nominations
please for
vice chair of licensing and regulatory
uh committee please proposal
absolutely councillor brynn harren
thank you do i have a sector
councillor beer
are there any further nominations
and i will ask the
[Music]
corporate manager governance and civic
office to
conduct the electronic vote thank you
chair that vote is now showing in blue
for councillors to cast their vote
thank you
councillor lindsay would you like to
cast your vote
thank you chair that is 24 4
2 against and three abstentions
thank you councillor carbondale
where are we up to here
got it
may i have nominations please for
uh co-chair of all joint audit and
standards committee please
counselor dave busby
thank you could i have a second to
please
counselor sue cottondale
[Music]
are there any further nominations
[Music]
then i will ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote please thank you
chair that vote to elect councillor
haran as co-chair of joint audience and
standards committee is now
open for councillors to place their vote
thank you
so
[Music]
councillor lindsay would you like to
place your vote please
thank you that is 27 votes four
one against and one abstention so that
is carriage here
thank you councillor
harren you're julia elected
[Music]
there's no there is no uh there's no
advice to you no guys chairman
so where are you joint appointments oh
yeah
may i have nominations for the co-chair
of joint appoints
appointments committee and could i have
a
proposal please
counselor clive arthy john ward
thank you and a second to please
counselor jan osborne
thank you are there any other
nominations
no okay then i will ask the
manager corporate corporate manager
governance and civic office
to connect conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now showing
in blue for council award to be
appointed as co-chair of joint
appointments committee
if councillors would like to place their
vote thank you
councillor lindsay would you like to
place your vote
thank you and councillor creswell i
haven't received your vote yet
okay oh yes it's just come through thank
you so um
chair that is 26 votes for and three
abstentions thank you
thank you council award is duel
appointed as
co-chair of joint appointments committee
all right i now turn to item 10
bc 21 stroke 4 four
appointments to outside bodies for 2021
22. i refer
to you appendix a in the table papers
i would like to invite the leader to
introduce paper bc
21 stroke 4 and move the recommendation
in the report
[Music]
i'd like to introduce this report bc 21
4 which is the appointment to the
outside bodies for 2021 to 22.
you'll find this report on page 27 of
your agenda pack
and also the appendix for the report
is on page seven of your agenda packs
supplement
um essentially the purpose of the report
is to consider the appointments to these
outside bodies
they're listed in appendix a very few
changes from
from last year um but the the purpose
obviously is we we do hold regular
reviews of uh this list of uh appointees
to outside bodies
and um they really the two-fold to
ensure that they
they're relevant um and the membership
is appropriate
um and that we have the um the correct
individuals in place
there are a number of criteria for this
the the criteria listed in section 3.2
of the report
but i'd like to move the recommendation
that councillors that
be appointed to the outside bodies as
detailed in appendix a
thank you chair thank you
could i have a seconder please
thank you councillor jan osborne
castle busby um
[Music]
i i think that is something that uh
it's anybody to make a nomination if
they want to put it yeah
yeah if there is anybody that wishes to
make a nomination for that
councillor councillor john
do the drains
uh
management scrutiny um
one of those ones that's left open it
might be an interesting subject
i don't think it means as often as
scrutiny which is
twice a year be prepared to take it on
yes
[Laughter]
do i need to i need to go to the so so
chair um
subject to that amendment if everybody's
an acceptance of that we can put
that paper straight to the vote with the
addition that council macro
is appointed to the east um drainage
board
it's him to blame so um chair that um
vote is now going to turn blue for
councillors to place their vote
thank you
i think this would be unanimous
councillor lindsay would you like to
place your vote
thank you councillor plum would you like
to place your vote
thank you and councillor dawson
okay chair that is um you know
unanimously for
uh councillor has to mccrawl you have uh
got the drains
[Music]
item 11 item 11
members appointment of councils to the
shared revenues partnership joint
committee
the nominations have been tabled could i
have a proposal
counselor john ward and could i have a
sector
councillor clive arthy
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic
office to conduct the electronic vote
thank you chair that
vote is now showing in blue and
councillors can place their vote thank
you
[Music]
so
councillor lindsay would you like to
place your vote
thank you
cancer beer are you having problems
would you like to place your vote
okay
so did you want to vote before you leave
okay and counselor dawson thank you
so chair that is 27 4 and 1 abstention
yeah thank you thank you for that
that is carried they are tabled
they are tabled uh documents so
that's a fair enough item
13 12. oh 12. i do beg your pardon
appointments to the suffolk joint
standards board
the nominations have been tabled could i
have a proposal
counselor dave busby and could i have a
secondar
councillor sue carpendale
i will now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now open
and showing in blue for councillors to
cast their vote
thank you
[Music]
counselor lindsay would you like to cast
your vote
thank you
councillor norman are you able to vote
it's gone blue now has it yeah okay
great stuff and councillor davis
yeah okay so that is um 27 4 and one
against thank you chair
that is carried
number 13
appointments to the joint gypsy and
traveller steering group
councillor is asked to support four
councillors to the gypsy
joint gypsy and travellers steering
group
nominations have been tabled please
could i have a proposal
counselor michael fraser could i have a
secondary
counselor clive arthy thank you
i'm now ask the corporate manager
governance and civic office to conduct
the electronic vote thank you chair that
vote
is now open and showing in blue for
councillors to cast their vote
thank you
[Music]
councillor lindsay can i have your vote
please
thank you chair that is 28th
that's unanimous thank you that is
carried
yes um item 14
appoints appointments to council working
groups
uh council is asked to appoint
councillors to the following working
groups
as table community governance review and
working group constitution
working group member learning and
development working group and the local
planned working group
could i have a proposal counselor john
ward
thank you could i have a second please
counsellor
now ask the corporate manager governance
and civic office to conduct the
electronic vote
thank you chair that vote is now open
and showing in blue
for councillors to cast their vote thank
you
[Music]
councillor lindsay would you like to
cast your vote
thank you and councillor holt would you
like to cast your vote
thank you chair again that's 28 4 that's
unanimously carried thank you thank you
thank you
uh item 15
bc 21 stroke 5 overview and scrutiny
committee
annual report 20 20 21
i would now very much like to invite
councillor alistair mccrawl
to introduce his report which is for
[Music]
noting
good evening everybody i hope you can
hear me clearly i'm here to
introduce the weber overview and
scrutiny committee annual report for
2020
to 2021. this is as noted for
just that noting you have the report in
your papers
today i think it's quite extensive and i
believe
it speaks for itself it follows the
format that we've used
over the last several years i'll be
happy to take any questions on that at
the end
but before i do i'd just like to give my
thanks to everybody that we've worked
with
over the last four years which is to say
almost
everybody this period was the first
chance for scrutiny to operate
under the cabinet system i hope that
we've collectively established a basis
for overview and scrutiny to provide the
essential balance between the needs of
cabinet
and council for the communities we all
serve
i have in the report specifically
mentioned the governance officers
with whom we've worked very closely they
bear mentioning again
henriette holloway has been our rock
throughout this time
jan robinson the corporate manager a
constant source of both advice
and planning for the future and emily
ewell the
final advisor as monitoring officer in
the more difficult
matters that sometimes face us i'm
eternally grateful to them all
and in their work they also represent
the work of all the officers that we've
worked with
the professionalism that we've seen in
these difficult times
has been remarkable so i'm remarking
council officers and staff should take
considerable pride
in what we've achieved in the last 15
months
members of the committee not least
adrian osborne as the vice chair
have been as hard working as any council
committee
finally it should be mentioned that we
have engaged with the cabinet
as they have with us taking note and
acting upon our recommendations
it is a two-way process and it feeds
back to you
the council the role of chairman of
overview and scrutiny has always been a
privilege
and often a pleasure and sometimes quite
challenging but scrutiny is an essential
and hopefully productive process i
believe
it to be in good hands so i ask you to
give your future support to the
committee
and i thank you i'm happy to take any
questions on the content of the report
itself
in that case i i don't know if i have to
propose that they'd be noted but i think
it's just a noted
matter yeah thank you thank you alistair
can i
just uh make a few comments that i think
is warranted here i've
been on the
ovn scrutiny in various forms over the
time i've been a councillor
and i cannot think of a person
counselor that has taken the chair
as so readily as as alistair has and the
work that he's carried out has been
absolutely
exceeding anything i've expected the
number of
uh things we've scrutinized is all to
his uh
great position in being chair
thank you alistair
nothing
it was really is it on it was really
just to echo that
um aleister took this on um with the the
formation of the
the new council two years ago um he's
stepping down to
to join the cabinet as you heard earlier
on i think we all
owe aleister a huge debt of gratitude
for what he's done
um with overview and scrutiny over the
past couple of years the way that he's
reported back to us he's had some really
difficult issues to deal with as you
probably know
and he's done a really good job so
thanks aleister
well done
[Applause]
all right
sorry uh john ward yeah
echo what counselor arthur said from the
point of view of cabinet
we i think that scrutiny has served a
very useful purpose particularly
in recent months there have been one or
two contentious issues
and scrutiny has done its job on behalf
of the council
and behalf on behalf of the our
residents
and that it has uh highlighted some
some areas where cabinet needed to think
again and um
i think that's been for all of our
benefit and
scrutiny now works very well and i'm
sure we'll continue to do so under the
new chair but thank you alastair
[Music]
thank you council award i've now
come to item 16 bc
stroke 21 stroke 6 over
you and scrutiny committee work plan
2021
22 and i would like to invite
alistair mccraw to introduce his report
which is for noting
[Music]
would that be in order for you to speak
to the forthcoming work plan council
mclaren
as opposed to me as the outgoing
chairman of speaking to it it seems to
me more appropriate
that you as the chairman now should deal
with that
i'm sorry to spring that only this was
not
would you have anything to say on that
thank you all i was going to say mary
was that we've
prepared additions to that work plan
that you have before you today
and it is mary and catherine who'll be
carrying that forward
yes can i just say that we had a very
good meeting yesterday which was
alistair's final meeting
and it was a joint overview and scrutiny
meeting
and we sort of gathered together the
things that we'd like to see
added to the established plan
one of the things we feel is that
training
not just for members of overview and
scrutiny but training for all
counsellors
keeping up to date with overview of
scrutiny and its aims and objectives
the other thing that i'm really
interested in is
some bespoke training around the
different skills of overview and
scrutiny
i proposed that yesterday because i
think there are hidden things that occur
during the lifetime of the
council and i've got to add my thanks to
emily ewell because she has been so
supportive over this past year
with unprecedented
action that has been had to be taken by
the
overview and scrutiny so we look forward
to
more integrated joint working with mid
suffolk
we want to establish pre-meetings to
prior to the overview and scrutiny
meeting we think that would be helpful
and we look forward to a very full
programme
thank you chair as i've said scrutiny is
in good hands
thank you mary councillor miriam thank
you aleister
mccraw for all your hard work
oh counselor
uh
[Music]
could i just start my comments um
aleister
well of course uh councillor barrett we
welcome your addition to the overview
and scrutiny
committee and
any ideas and
proposal you wish to put then we're all
going to review that
and that will happen
i think you're quite right i think over
the last year we've proved
as as a committee that we've reacted
quite well to the changes
not only in virtual meetings but in
the effects of the pandemic on our
communities
so i'm very happy that for you to
suggest
and contribute to the committee thank
you
thank you clarence councillor mclaren
councillor dave busby
[Music]
september
well is that well if it helps the
chairman's uh
charity yes we'll do that
[Music]
thank you council busby any more
questions
from the floor
i think you've done well counselor i can
go now thank you very much
[Music]
yes cruel very cruel
um that's it um just um
just for the benefit of all your members
the
the next meeting will be on tuesday the
20th of july 2021
at 5 30. the whereabouts is still
unsure but i hope it
will be as as councillor catherine
grandin has already said to be all
together it's nice to have everybody
here
face to face instead of on a virtual
meeting which is a little bit
a little bit scary at times can i
just pay a a a tribute to
our governance officers as alistair has
already done
uh and also the um uh
worsted park itself for their for their
nice uh setup
and the uh involvement of of
everybody on the staff excellent
and um i would like to say give my
sincere thanks to you councillor um
manager of the governance thank you for
you
for your hard work thank you
okay that closes the meeting
you